thundercats was a kid's cartoon that
promoted righteous acts but if it was
such a pure program then how come the
showrunners had to bring in a
psychologist to review the scripts the
answer to this question and more awaits
in the 1980s most animated kids shows
served as half hour advertisements for
their respective toy lines while
thundercats was no different the
franchise's origins are far more earnest
the beloved animated series was dreamed
up by the late ted wolf in 1981 however
the creation of thundercats was more of
a family affair as revealed by his
daughter janice woof told the honolulu
advertiser about the thought process
that went into the creation of the
series
we sat around the table creating the
characters it was a morality play with
superheroes basically the characters
have survived pretty much as they were
intended after the family workshopped
the idea together wolfe took some
sketches of the characters and the
overall story concept to tell a
pitcher's corporation the thumbs up came
from the executives and the thundercats
roared into action four years later
hitting tv screens in 1985.
thundercats was all about good values
and doing the right thing lionel and his
friends were paragons of virtue the show
inspired young children to fight against
the kinds of behavior that would furrow
the brows of their parents and teachers
that's why it was so shocking when some
explicit outtakes in which the voice
actors let loose made their way onto the
internet and anyway it was just plain
stupid to assume it might be bad just
what am i talking about at first many
fans of the original show presumed these
outtakes were false recorded by people
who were good at impersonating the
characters however lionel voice actor
larry kenny later confirmed they were
genuine in an interview with
thundercats.org
yes the outtakes on the web are real and
all of us cast members feel badly that
they are available for young people to
hear kenny added that he was heartbroken
to receive an email from a young fan
asking if lino really said such horrible
things the veteran voice actor blamed
one of the show's sound engineers for
leaking the r-rated content we had no
idea those things would ever be heard
outside the recording studio
oh lionel
we're not
what's the matter snark
lionel is a name as instantly
recognizable as he-man she-ra or optimus
prime
even those who have never watched an
episode of thundercats know that the guy
with the orange mane and the cool sword
is the group's fearless leader what few
people know is this iconic character had
a different name in the series pitch
miss prissy pence stop fussing with your
balls sucks
uh no his original name wasn't miss
prissypants he was originally called
lionel it's easy to understand why they
changed it the lionel richie jokes would
have been all too easy to make the
thundercats lead wasn't the only
character with a different name in the
pitch chitara was known as cheetah jagga
was known as jaguar panthro was panthar
and tigra was tigar the naming
convention for the supporting characters
was fairly obvious to spot but we have
to wonder why lion o wasn't called lyo n
using that same formula regardless the
final name selected were probably for
the best and most fans simply can't
imagine these classic characters under
any other guys
thundercats immediately evokes memories
of the heroic lino the skilled chitara
the super smart tigra or even the
sinister villain mumra
one character that most fans would
rather forget is the annoying schnarf
who didn't do much other than make weird
noises and get in the way the creators
of the 2011 thundercats reboot almost
got rid of the shrill voiced furball as
showrunner michael jalanick revealed
snarf came very close to getting the axe
and then he was reimagined as sort of a
tough battle cat like a doberman pincher
version of snarf but a cat why was snarf
even introduced in the first place peter
lawrence one of the writers of the
original thundercats answered this
question for thundercatsfans.org
snarf was invented by executive producer
jules bass bass invented snarf because
he wanted light relief and as he said
everyone loves some kind of wacko animal
despite the general animosity towards
snarf we cannot deny that he has
established himself as part of the
thundercats legacy for better or for
worse
i liked it there have been several
transformers and teenage mutant ninja
turtles movies over the years but we've
yet to see a big screen live-action
adaptation of thundercats that's set to
change in the near future as godzilla vs
kong director adam wingard has signed on
to helm a feature film based on the
famous 80s cartoon
the good news for fans is that wingard
is a major fan of the franchise he even
wrote a thundercat screenplay when he
was a teenager
wingard told deadline my real obsession
with thundercats came in high school the
pinnacle of me deciding i wanted to be a
filmmaker and pushing in that direction
i didn't pay attention in school made
terrible grades and the reason i was
writing my thundercat screenplay through
my entire 10th grade year
wingard revealed that he wrote his
272-page script by hand and still has
all the notebooks when he learned that a
thundercat script was doing the rounds
in hollywood he asked the attached
producers if he could rework it he went
on to say this about his enthusiasm for
the project this is a huge passion thing
for me nobody on this planet knows or
has thought as much about thundercats as
i have
thundercats arrived on television a few
years after george lucas's original star
wars trilogy came to a close the galaxy
far far away didn't only inspire the
next generation of sci-fi and fantasy
properties but it also carried a
powerful message of how redemption is
possible for even the biggest villains
darth vader had become corrupted by his
anger turning to the dark side of the
force but when it mattered most he
rediscovered his humanity and did what
was right the good vs evil element of
star wars permeated throughout every
thundercats episode however the animated
show also paid tribute to lucas's space
opera in another way chatting with
thundercats fans.org writer and
character designer dennis woodyard
revealed that he included an homage to
star wars in the episode shadow master
mimicking a famous scene from the films
one of my favorite parts was the ending
where lionel's father appears next to
jaga that was my nod to star wars
like the ending of return of the jedi
where the force ghosts of anakin
skywalker obi-wan kenobi and yoda
appeared to luke skywalker this scene
was important to lionel it showcased his
mentors effectively passing on the
leadership of the thundercats to him
at first glance thundercats is your
typical sword and sorcery show below the
surface however there's a story that
digs a little deeper than a simple plot
about villains wanting a magical item
from the heroes yes the primary goal was
to create a demand for thundercats
action figures and make lots of money
but every episode of the show also
imparted wisdom and moral values to the
children watching in an interview with
fansite thundercats.org larry kenny
argued that thundercats has stood the
test of time due to its inherent
positive message this moral underpinning
helped set it apart from many other
shows of the era kenny said thundercats
was conceived at a time when the tv
industry was being criticized for
bombarding children with violence and
negativity we attempted to entertain
kids and at the same time show that
problems can be solved without violence
by people working together
nowadays it isn't unusual for television
shows to have eye-watering budgets for
example the lord of the rings the rings
of power is expected to set amazon back
over a billion dollars according to the
hollywood reporter the 1980s was a time
of overspending but these kinds of
numbers were still unheard of especially
when it came to animated kids shows so
how did a series about cat-like aliens
managed to secure a multi-million dollar
commitment according to a clipping from
the saint joseph news press dated
september 21 1985 thundercats cost 15
million dollars to produce then
president of the telepitchers
corporation michael garan and arthur h
loomis vp of finance and administration
confirmed this number was accurate the
reason for this large investment was
simple telepitchers secured a guarantee
from tv stations to air the animated
show for three years and in return the
stations would get a cut of the toy
sales it was a classic case of spending
money to make money
not every kids show idea that's slapped
against a whiteboard ends up getting
made as there are numerous boxes to tick
and hoops to jump through when it comes
to children's programming
the 1980s was an era renowned for parent
groups lobbying and protesting over kids
shows and the people behind thundercats
were all too keenly aware of this the
show instilled a few basic but important
checkpoints in the production process
these were to ensure that the series
would never end up in the limelight for
the wrong reasons like many of its
contemporaries
as revealed by former writer lee
schneider in a huff post column a
psychologist was employed to read every
script and determine if the story was
appropriate for children or not of
course what is considered appropriate
for kids differs from person to person
schneider jokingly remarked about this
measure in his column about the show
if you check the statistics during the
period the cartoon aired you'll see that
murder rates went down school attendance
went up and sat scores went through the
roof when kids weren't scoring really
high on their sats or busy not
committing crimes they were peeing their
beds scared to death with nightmares of
mumrah the bad guy of thundercats
remember that time the internet believed
michael bay's sixth underground was
secretly a live-action thundercats film
and the story had to be debunked by ryan
reynolds the deadpool star has been
linked to the role of lionel in adam
wingard's upcoming feature film and he's
not the first x-men actor to insert
himself into the conversation speaking
to total film james mcavoy revealed that
he grew up loving thundercats and that
he wanted to see a film based on the
franchise the scottish star said
lionel is a great character for any
actor
it's kind of explored a little bit in
the cartoon but you could really go for
a 12 year old in the body of a man like
a ripped muscly fighting man who is
meant to be the king of these people but
he's got a 12 year old's intellect
mcavoy went on to joke that the role
could lead to an academy award if played
correctly
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you